blondie im barbie waren und jetzt will
sie blöd werden ernsthaft prognose mein
großes ziel ist eine hirnlose partie zu
sein
herzlich kommt sollen wieder leute in
dem ich mir ein video für uns ausgesucht
habe das ist wählt ihr auch gleich sehen
extrem ist ihr werdet euch in den
nächsten sekunden des kandels
garantieren an den kopf fasst und euch
denken
wo bin ich denn jetzt genannt und zwar
leute haben wir mal wieder ja wirklich
mal wieder mittlerweile denkt ich würde
ja wie viele leute von dieser art kann
es auf der welt geben eine frau die
barbie sein möchte aber aber der große
unterschied zwischen ihren allen anderen
ist dass sie wirklich zu den extremsten
mitteln greift die man sich vorstellen
kann
schau mal rein ihr aussehen verstören
für viele jenseits des guten geschmacks
für blondie bennert aber gerade erst der
anfang
also das ist die blondie beendet heißt
die 38 jahre alt und ganz ehrlich mit
mittlerweile frage ich mich wo kommen
all diese leute her wo finden fernseh
crews diese leute die barbie werden
wollen vor allem leute das krasseste ist
ja immer diese ganze frauen die so wie
barbie sein wollen sind immer so total
aufgeblasen und um operiert und alles
mögliche barbies eigentlich so sie war
ja eigentlich was man sich schon ein
schönheitsideal so wollte ich immer
aussehen inzwischen aber wenn ich es
noch extremer
ein schönheitsideal ist eine
plastikpuppe wenn allerdings die
plastikpuppe halt zu greifen zu kleine
brüste
deswegen habe ich mir gerade im mai
basketbälle einsetzen lassen blondie im
barbie waren und jetzt will sie blöd
werden ernsthaft prognose sei es sagt es
einfach nicht sagt mir einfach nicht was
dein großes ziel ist lass mich dir
vorher die frage stellen möchte von
allen guten geistern verlassen
die leute wirklich es ist es ist nicht
leicht solche videos zu sehen und nicht
den glauben an die menschheit zu
verlieren wie kann man denn sich zum
ziel machen und blöder zu werden
die gavi wie kann man nehme mein großes
ziel ist eine hirnlose partie zu sein
aber auch eine störung
wo bin ich gelacht wird lena gerne das
trifft zu den kommentaren genau auf den
kopf wo bekommt haft diese leute her
wirklich ich weiß okay heute in amerika
sind teilweise relativ hängen gebliebene
leute ist wirklich so muss ich sagen
aber wenn ich mir vorstelle ich bin
amerikaner selbst wenn ich davon ahnt
wohne und dann werde ich eines tages von
einem 40 tonner laster angefahren auf
der autobahn
ich glaube auch an diesem punkt würde
ich immer noch nicht ankommen
ich denke nicht dass sie die verblödung
beruf brauche meine herzog noch und ich
atme also bin ich noch ein mensch aber
wenn ich die wahl hätte wäre ich lieber
aus plastik und zwar zu 100 prozent
ok jetzt jetzt wird zugleich sein also
gerade irgendwann doch soweit okay die
frau hat wahrscheinlich ein dachschaden
so sie ist nicht an den hörsaal bisschen
mehrere ziele im leben aber jetzt sitzen
die blondine bei der hypnotherapie tief
einatmen klingt es aus ihrem laptop ganz
ruhig und entspannt atmen
es klingt hier einen blondinenwitz ist
dabei war es aber ganz ehrlich leute was
denkt sich gott jetzt dabei wenn er das
hier sieht also keine ahnung wenn jetzt
muslime seit oder oder you do whatever
egal nimmt geht mit auf einer geschichte
okay was denkt sich gott oder wer auch
immer diese welt geschaffen hat hat
damals im universum geschwebt ein paar
tage gearbeitet hat den menschen
erschaffen dachten sich marschall
das ist doch wirklich mal ein gutes ding
und dann 20.000 jahre später die
menschen sind an dem punkt angekommen wo
sie einfach aktiv dümmer und aus plastik
sein wollen zweimal wöchentlich gibt
sich blondie beide tiere hypnose sitzung
hin nicht um zu entspannen nein die 38
jährige verfolgt nur ein ziel um werden
die völlige verblödung da ist ja
wirklich nicht mehr weiterhin also ich
muss ganz ehrlich sagen ich glaube sie
hat wirklich also ist mittlerweile
geistig nicht mehr so ganz da ich glaube
da ist wahrscheinlich irgendwas
unverarbeitet im hintergrund oder so
allein schon die tatsache dass man sich
in eine verblödung snow zz top ihre
hände gibt gibt ja schon auf dass
darüber dass man schon auf dem gewissen
level an blödheit ist um überhaupt
anzufangen
ich möchte einfach ausschalten
das geil ist dass sie das eigentlich
gerade bei mir auslöst ohne dass ich es
will sie willst schafft es vielleicht
nicht ganz so wie sie es schon gut dabei
ich will es nicht sehe dieses video
aber genau das ist der effekt beim
eintritt noch keiner nach amerika gehen
der helfen bitte bitte leute
irgendjemand männer die mich gut finden
sie zahlen meine operationen
die gar nicht braucht aber auch da hat
die frage leute die frage an meine
liegen mit männer warum warum
unterstützt man das auch noch keine
ahnung könnt ihr eure partnerin nicht
dabei unterstützen dass sie irgendwie
eine karriere aufbauen dass sie sich als
persönlichkeit weiterentwickeln und ich
auf dem weg zum plastikpuppe zu werden
ich hab's du weißt du wer wird zum neuen
traum ich wäre ganz gerne genauso wie
ein 20 zentimeter großes unbeliebtes
plastikspielzeug nützen mich dabei
unterstützen
masala machen sondern setzen auch ihren
lebensunterhalt
wenn sie nicht mit mir zum schauen
können schicken sie mit geld aus sagen
die psychologen wie dr michael korn und
setzten den verträgen blondie manager
psychisch krank danke danke danke danke
danke danke leute danke endlich mal ein
vernünftiger mensch in dieser ganzen
okay jetzt bin ich mal sehr gespannt auf
ihre fachkundige meinung was wieder zu
sagt vermute die fachkundige meinung
wird ungefähr so aussehen
hängengeblieben das ist bizarr womöglich
aber auch eine störung mehr bezeichnen
es als körper wahrnehmungsstörung das
gefährliche daran ist dass die
betroffenen niemals mit sich zufrieden
sind
auch bei blondie gab es ja schon einige
operationen ja das ist wirklich
geisteskrank leute wissen wir wissen was
ist was meine meinung ist ich glaube das
ist so der der ultimative aus wachs und
die endstufe von dem druck der so auf
mädchen heutzutage lassen hat gut
auszusehen ja also der ist ja auf jeden
fall da und mädels gehen mit dem
unterschiedliche um manche haben damit
weniger probleme manche mehr
ich glaube die absolute spitze an
probleme mit schönheits druck oder was
auch immer ist das ja sogar im leben
abgeschlossen hast dass du einfach eine
plastikpuppe sein willst ich möchte
einfach und dafür möchte sie ihre rest
intelligenz opfern zweimal wöchentlich
nimmt sie dafür in einer hypnose sitzung
teil verständlich ihr therapeut
unerkannt bleiben
ach therapeut as a hat das ganze vom
therapeuten gemacht also von einem
menschen der sich eigentlich dazu
verpflichtet dass es leute besser geht
ja ok wobei weil allerdings von man
könnte schon diskutieren ob es ihr nicht
besser geht wenn sie einfach den apparat
hier oben einfach komplett raus
schmeißen aus plastik sein und
abzustumpfen bedeutet nichts mehr zu
empfinden
man opfert seine identität und lebt eine
andere die einer puppe new york new york
diese frau hat zwar extrem rote auch ich
weiß nicht ob wir sind traurig findet
die krankheit ist aber leute das ist
genau auf meinen standpunkt an der
ganzen sache da kann irgendwas glaube
ich bei ihnen nicht ganz funktioniert
haben irgendwas ist in ihrem leben
richtig schief gelaufen und sie fügt
sehr negativ über ihr leben und versucht
deswegen so eine andere identität rhein
zu flüchten also ich finde es muss ja
schon extrem viel passiert sein dass man
sagt okay ich mag nicht mehr gewährt
plastikpuppe sein egal hauptsache die
leute bewundern mich rechtfertigt sich
die pseudo barbie und monster wird ihre
paar fans die breite masse aber ist bei
den anblick er verwundert
ganz ehrlich ich würde wirklich alles
gute wünschen dass sie wieder halbwegs
klar kommt weil ich glaube dass ist
wirklich eine verdrängungsstrategie
wahrscheinlich was sie gerade macht
leute eine stadt zu über ihre probleme
zu reden sich damit auseinanderzusetzen
befürchtet sie sich halt da rein
möglichst wie barbie halt nicht einig
wie barbie so habe ich war immer war das
vorbild aber wie sieht das ganz anders
aus als sie ihr wisst was ich meine
also das war jetzt heute wirklich
teilweise creepy leute haben die
kommentare was ihr davon gehalten habt
schaut euch hin für euch vorgeschlagen
dass wir hier oben könnt ihr beim kanal
bringen ich bin raus macht's gut